we've received a lot of questions online
mr. Trump about the tape that was
released on Fridays you can imagine you
called what you said locker room banter
you described kissing women without
consent grabbing their genitals that is
sexual assault you bragged that you have
sexually assaulted women do you
understand that I didn't say that at all
I don't think you understood what was
that this was locker room talk I'm not
proud of it I apologize to my family I
apologized to the American people
certainly I'm not proud of it but this
is locker room talk you know when we
have a world where you have Isis
chopping off heads where you have and
frankly drowning people in steel cages
where you have Wars and and horrible
horrible sites all over where you have
so many bad things happening this is
like medieval times we haven't seen
anything like this the carnage all over
the world and they look and they see can
you imagine the people that are frankly
doing so well against us with all due
respect I didn't understand a single
word you just said did you really just
compare the hideous crimes of Isis with
your sexual assault on women no way
didn't know that all maybe maybe they
did yes that is possible maybe not to be
honest I can't remember and I don't want
one question is it really the right time
for water-cooler chitchat about some
harmless locker room talk about some
highly hypothetical she grabbing while
Isis and clear these are male either
times so what we need is a medieval
president like me all of my thinking and
my treatment of women is outright
medieval I'm not proud of it
it's no crime I tell you what is a crime
everything that crooked Hillary has done
she invented Isis because she is an evil
evil woman and when I'm president I
promise I will put her on trial and
personally chop off her nasty wicked
head I'm sorry to interrupt again but I
really think you're getting off track
here can we please get back to my
question I will stop Isis I will build a
wall to stop them very cheaply by
illegal Mexicans well afterwards stay
behind it where they can rape thank you
clean the houses of their own people and
I will also build a tremendous class
don't over America to keep it safe from
rain I have a so called climate change
which doesn't exist it doesn't exist at
all it's an invention of the Chinese but
I will defeat it anyway oh crap that
filthy climate change by the sea rode
back to China that's what I'll do I'm
sorry but we really have to stop this
debate I don't think you're ever going
to answer my question about the remarks
you make wrong you lie I did answer I
said it's locker room talk but it's not
my fault crooked Hillary had more than
30 years to stop it to outlaw locker
room talk she could have stopped it
forever when she wasn't Congress but she
didn't
so if i say that i want to grab some
it's really she was grabbing because she
didn't stop me from saying oh i sis okay
I think you've completely lost your mind
now your nurses will be here any moment
but we have to say goodbye to the people
No thank you no no no no no you can't
stop me now
nobody can and believe me when I am
sitting on the president's throne in the
White House in King's Landing I swear to
God which is me anyway I will make sure
but no president of this great country
will ever have to answer stupid
questions like this again as long as I
am the American president I pray that
will never happen never underestimate
the power of stupid people in large
groups and now you can count our
population and call me mr. president
[Music]